all right I'll start over again
um so I'm opening the subcommittee work
session on Senate Bill 207. I've handed
out to everyone Amendment 1982 h
and it just changes
um
section 7 which deals with the definite
of the emergency medical and Trauma
Services critical critical incident
intervention management and what I was
saying is that
this just changes
um membership of the teams or and who
can
Point people to it basically and the
main point of doing this at all is so
that um you know if a fireman or
policeman has been through a traumatic
situation
is being counseled by
you know other members
that the people that that the people
helping them are
allowed to maintain confidentiality
because I think the last thing you need
if you're trying to
deal with being through something
traumatic is to be worried about you
know censoring your words because you're
afraid something might be used against
you basically so and similarly I mean
mental health professionals have that
protection lawyers uh ministers that
so uh your name is on the amendment but
this is the language is as you as your
remarks imply is uh similar to or
identical to an uh statutory language
that's already out there for other
professions to your knowledge
um
not exactly well I mean the the
this is making some changes to existing
statute right the existing statutes
there and it's uh adding
and this is the language that was agreed
to by the police and fire folks
so thank you that was my assumption from
your remarks and yeah the only the only
difference is OLS caught one other place
in here where uh
peer support group language was in there
and that was taken out as well it's it's
now not used at all I guess that's
actually used in a different context and
that was providing some
concern
and possibly confusion so any anybody
else have any any other discussion
questions
okay uh not seen any uh would somebody
like to make a motion
maybe to uh adopt this amendment or I
can
yeah I'll move them in okay
uh sec I'll second it
so any any other discussion on the
amendment
all right see none
um
so we're voting whether or not one other
thing I'll say is that you know there's
the non-termaine amendment to SB 207 and
possibly other things so the if we vote
to accept this
and or and recommend that to the full
committee then I think the full
committee and exact session later today
is going to have a vote on this on uh
Jackie's non-germaine Amendment and
there's another issue
and however that vote comes out then
there'll be a combined Amendment drafted
and we'll have to exec it at the next
meeting just to accept that Amendment
but that's the process so
yep
the confidentiality aspect I mean you
have some could that be used for ill as
well as well
we're going to cover up this thing by
you being my counselor well that that
doesn't
the person counseling them can't be
required to divulge what was said but
that doesn't prevent and the members of
your peer group right but that doesn't
well that doesn't prevent any other
investigation or disciplinary process
from proceeding so it doesn't provide
protection outside of people who have
been assigned to provide you counseling
dealing with the issue but I think it
specifically says that they you can't be
compelled to testify
um the one who can't be compelled to
testify is the person who's counseling
you
except that's providers you can see no
person with a critical incident stress
management team member or team leader or
peer group support member providing or
receiving critical incident stress
management Crisis Intervention or peer
support services shall be required to
testify or divulging information
obtained solely so through such Crisis
Intervention right solely through
exactly so any other I mean if there was
no
let's say they weren't involved in this
uh uh peer counseling thing you know
there's uh
things in place to for uh investigations
I mean criminal or just internship
everybody involved in the peer group ah
yeah you're kind of absolving them from
telling the truth about something that
went bad you know well
I I get what you're you're getting at
but I think that if um
you know everybody was involved in an
incident is is part of that's made part
of the peer support group I think that's
not going to look good and there will be
and any other investigation can still
perform so Yeah by an outside person
who's not equipped with the information
uh once you are working or or the
department or the AG or you know
right
no you're aware of that and you're
anything else
okay
um we're going to take a vote on
adopting
Amendment 1982 H to Senate bill 207.
representative Smith
representative Bailey yes
uh representative goalie
and I vote Yes so that's
um you know four
four to zero all right
the chairman knows this but I'm not home
I know that's why I didn't call on you
oh that's it for people so people know
why you didn't vote right
you're we are aware of that I just want
the other subcommittee members to
understand that I'm not on the floor
okay I'm going to close the uh work
session subcommittee work session on
Senate Bill 207
and I'm going to open the subcommittee
work session on Senate bill
okay
um
if people remember from the last
subcommittee work session
um
I had pointed out that what RSA here
that RSA 170-e50
grants uh DHHS rulemaking authority to
create
professional certification for child
care programs and in fact as I
understand it
all the other certification for child
care programs was done through
rulemaking
and um
so it didn't seem like this was
necessary and you know the question was
why
you know whether there's something to
prevent DHHS from creating this
certificate through rulemaking or if
there is there's some reason they didn't
and I sent
um at least everybody in the
subcommittee
uh some email exchanges between myself
and Diane Chase of DHHS and Carol
McGuire
and they have DHHS is committed to
creating this certification through
rulemaking
and they said they can do it and they
will do it uh chair Maguire said she's
going to send them an official letter
letter from the Edna committee letting
them know that that's what we expect
them to do
and so what I I'd like to propose
um retaining this bill
and if they do proceed and do this to
rulemaking then in the fall we can I
tell it and if they don't then well we
can make them
so any discussion on that
okay I'll second that okay I'll move it
you second it all right
um any any further question or
discussion on this okay makes perfect
sense all right sorry about this
representative Smith
represent Bailey yes representative
goalie and I vote Yes
and so I'm closing the subcommittee work
session on Senate Bill 106 and we're
done with this subcommittee
um so for everybody who's in the room
the subcommittee on the pension does
have a subcommittee meeting going from
10 to 10 30 although I'm hoping it won't
take quite that long to get this done
um I've handed out to all of the
subcommittee members uh amendments
2023-1951h it basically just replaces
the whole bill
uh with the updated building codes that
the building code review board has
approved to allow these new refrigerants
to operate in the state of New Hampshire
safely
um I sent out that information last
night if you are super curious in it you
could have looked through the 47 pages
of code
um but did anybody on the subcommittee
have any
comment about this amendment or any
just for the record Mr chairman so the
changes
are just lines 15 and 16 and 16. yep
right we passed legislation similar
earlier that was November 30th so they
just had this meeting and updated these
codes and then are looking for approval
on the ones for the reflections I I I
believe I understand and I'm okay with
that
okay
yes representative true
thank you Mr chair
um is anyone speaking today
not that I'm aware of is there anybody
who'd like to
um I don't think so according to my uh
very extensive notes
what we wanted to avoid is not having
this in rsas and building codes
separately correct
and that's the way this corrects but it
does that this this gets it to the
finalized product that we want
without having to do the multiple steps
any other questions
representative
second second by representative Schmidt
any conversation
comment
representative
um
doing what everyone wanted and requested
and what needed to be done
um
I hope this comes out of the committee
uh with a positive recommendation and
hope under the subcommittee with a
positive recommendation great
ditto
all right I will call the roll on it
then uh the motion before us is
um
the adoption of amendment 2023 on oh
sorry two zero two three one nine five
one-h
um to SB 53.
um
representative Schmidt yes
representative true yes representative
gerhardt
all right with that then I would
yes we'll we'll move the
yes
oh yes and the chair votes yes as well
I'm going I'm going a little too fast
um so having adopted the amendment I
would move all to pass as Amendment
amended on SB 53
um do I have a second on that
representative true uh
I don't have anything to say
representative true
any other comment all right I will call
the roll then the move it um motion is
ought to pass on SB 53 as amended uh
representative Davis
representative Schmidt with Amendment
yes representative sorry representative
true
representative Gerard
and the chair votes yes all right that
we're off until 10 30.
done yet
but everybody will be happy to be
notified that they're all ready for us
I've spoken with the events manager this
morning and everything is ready to go
and we'll talk about directions
foreign
good morning before we get to our
executive session we have two bills that
the Senate has amended
the first one is House Bill 409
which was completely replaced by a
I believe 50 page Amendment
and which includes a lot of words from
uh House Bill 655 and some other points
and the social work compact
so I'm going to recommend we go to
Committee of conference on that because
this is the side-by-side analysis
uh I don't think we can decide
we want to talk to the have the
committee read the bill
read the amendment and discuss with the
Senate what they think they're doing
any anybody have objections to that
okay
I will forward the uh
uh electronic version the one one paper
copy should be plenty
all right so uh if nobody objects I'll
tell the clerk that is there anyone
interested in serving on that
subcommittee on the committee of
conference
okay
what's up
I did she heard okay yeah well I'll I'll
put you on the list and anybody else if
if you don't say you're not interested
you're subject to being appointed
so
so anyhow that that one looks like it's
it's it's got to be discussed
the other one is House Bill 461 which
left us as requiring a penalty if a
municipality
uh chose to replace a full-time
high level position with part-time
and the Senate amended it to make it a
study committee on this on the subject
I'm inclined to say just don't Concur
and let and let somebody bring something
in next year if they still care
uh does anybody have strong feelings on
that
you'd like to study no I don't
yeah that's what I was saying okay
so Simon
Raymond and goalie want to go to
Committee of conference I'm happy with
that
any objections
representative Schmidt does not want to
be on that Committee of conference
okay yeah
fine representative true
um but we're going to Committee of
conference to defend that position
absolutely and nothing less
right
yeah can't do more
all right
all right so we will uh I'll I'll tell
the clerk that and we'll get to that
and
and let's see these are our last Senate
bill so if we reach reach agreement on
them today we will not have to come back
as a committee so
there we go Senate Bill 207 Tony you
have a subcommittee Amendment
you could explain it emotion explain it
to us and uh
so this is
um Amendment 1982 H to Senate Bill 207
and just uh refresh people this this
bill
um is related to a situation where
you've got police or fire who are in
some traumatic situation
and um
you know other other such people
can provide counseling and by having
that set up the people doing the
counseling are covered under another
part of the statute that provides them
with some exceptions
confidentiality the idea is that if
you've dealt with a traumatic situation
and you're talking with somebody you
kind of work through it it's not helpful
if you have to uh carefully censor what
you say because you're worried it might
be used against you and it's for the
same same reasons that mental health
professionals have that confidentiality
and you know religious ministers pastors
and whatever
um
and the amendment
was agreed to between the uh the police
and the fire folks and it just changes
you know who can who the members can be
and who can um it adds to who can
so originally this Bill had a study
committee in the did you leave that in
there
um I my understanding of what Carol's
planning is we'll deal with that issue
separately this amendment
by itself doesn't remove it
but
um you can also have another amendment
right I mean there's I think we're going
to be voting at least three things for
this and one of them is a study
committee but that's not in this amount
yeah okay so there'll be other
amendments on this bill that's my
understanding okay there's a rather
Hefty one is yours for example
so this is purely about section seven
the medical service Emergency Services
um
so moved by representative
Lucas and is it seconded
okay
and any anyone else have comments
and while we're here anyone who doesn't
recognize representative Schultz is
filling in for Representatives
Fitzpatrick
all right if there's no further
discussion the motion is to adopt
Amendment 1892.
oh sorry the clerk will call the
limestone
representative Simon yes representative
blakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative santoso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan
representative a bear yes representative
Gerard yes clerk votes yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes representative
O'Brien yes representative grassy yes
representative Davis yes representative
Schultz yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes 20a09
right
representative Crowder you have another
amendment
I do
um
just a moment I move non-germaine
Amendment and I don't have the numbers
1915. thank you it's 1915 and it's the
one that we had the hearing on on Monday
okay
okay do you want to introduce this uh
Amendment here yes the amendment
um defines
um expands the licensure for social
workers to a um
something it's on a temporary I'm just
searching for the word thank you
it's a conditional license so that
individuals don't have to wait for
licenses as they're moving into the
state so if they meet the requirements
of the and they already have a license
in good staying with other states they
can have a control license for New
Hampshire
foreign
well I gave them on Monday to out to the
committee and I don't have one an extra
one right now were you here I'm sorry I
can get you one we we discussed it on
Monday
absolutely
it's just
yeah
I mean you could have missed it
okay
representative Brody it Luke reads to me
is though this is for someone who is
uh
still doesn't meet all the requirements
for license but is working on them yes
okay so that might apply to people who
are registering here for the first time
yes and just need the supervised
practice yes okay thank you that makes
sense the way of making
um Healthcare
social workers more accessible
for school social workers
Associates
any other discussion comment comments
questions
um the only thing I'll point out I I had
suggested a slight change to
representative groda's Amendment because
there are several places in the
amendment that it refers to an acronym
cswe when I was actually looking at it I
was saying to myself well is that c
clinical or certified or exactly what is
that so I went back to the original
statute and the first place that that
acronym is listed it still doesn't
explain it I I went through my notes and
discovered that it should be the Council
on social workers education so so that's
on page three line 15.
yeah okay
um uh and I'm just suggesting that
um
if we adopt this amendment that that
should be clarified for statutes
someplace well I think perhaps it could
be done as an enrolled Amendment if the
committee agrees uh I think we're going
to be
dealing with the previous Amendment as
well so this will not be the final
Amendment so we might as well spell it
without objection we'll change this on
page 3 line 15 to spell out c c a c r e
p
no it's page page one online 31. Adam
Chad
oh
yeah that's the first
that's the only one I couldn't see that
anywhere else
but line 22 as well line 22 yeah that
fine so line 22 being higher we spell it
out on that one right okay spell out the
acronym is there any objection to doing
so
okay we'll do that as an editorial
comment then
thank you any other issues with this
amendment
just I just want to point out that it
also creates a um
doesn't this create a committee or
commission committee
yes
and um that's in the original Bill not
the amendment oh and we will
oh I see that's the amended analysis
all right
so any other discussion on Amendment
our grammar
okay seeing none the motion is to adopt
the amendment now the clerk can call the
role
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Weber yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk votes
yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Schultz yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes 20 a zero
name
[Music]
creates the study committee on licensure
Mental Health Professions
um I don't have a formal Amendment for
that but I move we delete it
just
I want to put out uh section one is
legislative findings I'm okay removing
it but it's not part of the committee ah
defined
I'll correct that to be sections two
is there a second
okay
and I'm doing this because the speaker
has asked us not to create any
unnecessary study committees when we had
the hearing we agreed that the timing
and schedule on this was not sufficient
to actually accomplish very much
and thirdly we already have several
retained bills on Mental Health
licensing and we will be looking into it
anyway we don't need a separate study
committee to keep doing what we plan to
do
uh representative Simon do you have
something to add
uh no you said it well thank you
anyone else representing Broda thank you
since I was on the city committee and I
was on the original bill for the study
committee I will support the motion
case the motion is to delete sections
two through six from Senate bill 207.
even Clerk and call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Weber yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk will
Jess representative yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Schultz yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes 20 years
early okay
all right so we have we will request a
composite Amendment which will
leave section one alone
delete sections two through six which is
the study committee replace section 7
and add sections 8 through 11 from
Amendment 1915.
and
okay
then section 7 is
um okay
the effective dates would be
for the
um
the conditional licenses 60 days after
passage which should be after Senate
Bill 655 goes into effect
the other one's on passage because
there's not a
not a question of interference
so
so the motion
is to amend Senate Bill 207 in these
I'll make that motion and is there a
second
representative blackis
all right I've said enough
representative Lucas
um I think we've covered it okay anyone
okay in that case the motion is to amend
Senate Bill 207 and the clerk can call
the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers representative Bailey yes
representative San Antonio yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Weber yes
representative Gerhard clerk vote Yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative schuette yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Schultz yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes 20 yay zero
name does anyone object to consent
seeing none will put it on consent Mr
Greenland would you deal with OLS to get
that Amendment
all right I have an amendment
um which is over on the table I'll pass
thank you I want to remind myself what I
did
okay
so um I moved Amendment
uh this bill is a
a revision to the marital masters board
at their request to reduce the number of
members and
um
so that they can have a quorum
so we agreed
that they should reduce the number of
members of the board
and
the bill the amendment has three parts
first it defines a quorum as three
I didn't want to put any limits on
people who were appointed I said I
figured if you have fewer than three
people there you can't really have an
effective meeting so Quorum is three
the marital Master Seat
being eliminated immediately is because
the there aren't any more marital
Masters
so it can't isn't filled can't be filled
and uh
we'll just eliminate it and then the
third part is to
delete the requirement for setting fees
in the requirements for interns and then
repeal RSA 328 C11 on fees because
that's all been
superseded by House Bill 655 and the
oplc fee set fee setting Authority
so
if anyone has any questions represent
true do you have a comment
um thank you Miss Madam chair you said
it well as in in testimony the problem
was the large board just could not meet
that was
the
major thing that needed to be corrected
all right in that case the motion is to
adopt Amendment 1636h
and the clerk called the role
representative Simon yes representative
Lagos yes representative Bailey yes
representative santoso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Weber yes
representative Gerard
clerk will just representative yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie
yes representative schuett yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick oh
I mean Schultz sorry
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes 20a09
right
yeah
and so I move ought to pass with
Amendment on house bill Senate bill 150.
I have nothing to say there's an
umbrella
no no okay representative Simon thank
you madam chair I'm just having a hard
time remembering this one for some
reason can anybody remind me what the
what the power or authority of this
board is
it's the over
marital mediates
okay so it's just overseeing it's it's a
standard professional okay just want to
make sure yeah and we're
slightly
without setting their quorum
and uh the leading fee Authority okay
fair enough
they still have all the professional
requirements as before
I might add it is there's 61 family
mediators in the court system how many
61 61 yeah the hearing was on March 30th
okay in that case the motion is ought to
pass as amended
on Senate bill 150.
I'm sorry representative Schmidt I know
it's as with Amendment
if I misspoke I apologize
any
Representatives sure you've got a
comment
I was just saying we we technically
cannot amend a bill the house has to do
it so we just send it to them with the
amendment right okay
as a
Senate Bill 150 with Amendment and the
clerk and call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey
yes representative santosasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard clerk votes yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative mashiewitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Schultz yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes
28-09 all right the motion passes 20-0
and the objection to consent
seeing none will put it on consent
that's the last video report I'm gonna
I believe you have an amendment I do
Madam chair
which is amendment that had a a it was a
non-germaine amendment that had a
hearing on Monday the 22nd
okay
um
second
do you wish to speak to your motion I do
thank you
uh Senate the amendment to sand bill
107.
um is a result of many hearings that we
had on the organizational structure of
oplc
and repeals the um
disciplinary proceeding four boards as
we discussed in many of the subcommittee
hearings
to make sure that the
discipline disciplinary hearings and the
disciplinary actions and the
investigation
at the investigation and education
and the um
oh my God what's the word I'm looking
for
um
find
adjudication could be separated thank
you
that's one of the things that it does
the other thing there's there are it
also
addresses public members shall be
independent from from the functions from
from the board Specialties and that was
not clearer
in
several of the boards so we did include
that
um
it does I'm looking for the page exactly
the number they're just to make sure
that those individuals who don't
participate in board meetings or
exhibit malfeasance shall be can be
removed from the board so it puts that
in one place that's a page uh the last
pet page 11. thank you section
67. and then on page 10
it um redefines the medical review
subcommittee
of the panel of clinicians
that assists oplc in investigations
so it gives the authority to the to oplc
to investigate
and the appointments from a panel
clinical clinicians will be conducted by
the executive director
so these are the four
do you wish to speak
no I think
as far as no one has any further
questions I think representative growth
explained it pretty well
representative Schmidt well here I think
it should be mentioned that it most
importantly it eliminates uh the section
of the Senate Amendment uh that was
causing lots of concern a members of the
public and a lot of other people so
that's completely deleted yes
yes and I would like to say that this is
it started as the sections we took out
of house bill 655 for further discussion
and Analysis and so it cleans up a lot
of language that
um
that we need the medical review
subcommittee has had some problems with
uh conflict of interest
and this language establishes that the
board will say what kind of people they
need and then the
oplc will appoint them to that
subcommittee
um there's one other thing the
um the electrician's board we want to
repeal
we want to delete I think it's line one
on page seven
that uh
removes their ability to appeal
to the building code Review Board in
cases of conflicts about the
interpretation of the building codes
because
it would be a lot easier to deal with
the building code review board than with
a judge in that case
um is that the line that we you agreed
to take out yeah okay so that's line one
any other questions comments
representative I just wanted to say that
representative Grodd and I went over
this in great detail with uh director
Courtney and uh
attorney osterhout and you know I'm fine
I guess we have I guess the
subcommittees have to be have beaten
comments questions seeing none the
motion is to adopt Amendment
1943 h
less
um
less line one on page seven right okay
have we got some more copies I'm looking
at
Amendment 1728 which is
um
not what we're really talking about uh
no this is the one we we had the
non-germaine hearing on Monday
right
oh
hear is
okay
I I'm sorry representative
um McGuire could we ask
um Mr Greenland to address that
Amendment with OLS
en so that we can get that done
thank you thank you so much yes thank
you that's the one line on page top of
so we should vote on the amendment first
yes
all right the motion is to adopt the
amendment
1943 h
as amended
and the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon
yes representative Lucas yes
representative Bailey yes represent
representative yes representative true
yes representative Dolan yes
representative Aber yes representative
Gerhard yes
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative will uh why is William
here grassy yes sorry it's an old sheet
sorry I apologize representative Davis
yes representative Schultz yes
representative gold yes representative
Smith
yes and the chair yes 28-09 okay
you have an amendment an emotion I do I
move OTP
on a pass with Amendment
on House Bill
both representative Gould yes thank you
I think I'm I've done enough this year
all right
um any further discussion comments
questions
all right
thank you very much
and
uh Murph you'd mention what the first
this bill refers to the general
administration of regulatory boards and
commissions
and um it gives an investigation
investigatory and legal expenses
um
except for those on the um under the
supervision of oplc
um to return to ex to retain expert
Witnesses
um it also
make sure that boards start final
commence final adjudication hearings
within two years
of the initial formal disciplinary
proceeding
and on its own initiative
and it can extend the time period if
and it talks about
um
and that's essentially the for that
that's section one section two talks
about individuals with a Criminal
with a prior criminal conviction
um
can be disqualified
um determining determined by
um
the board and the commission
it also talks it also allows for
petition
um period of 90 days
and the individual can pay can appeal a
determination so it's really a procedure
that
looks at occupation occupational
licensure for applicants with criminal
convictions
son of gold do you have a comment
no no Madam chair I think representative
Grody covered it
anyone else
representative yep
um
yeah
this thing did originally uh repeal
um the right to petition the board for
review of a criminal record however the
amendment we just adopted uh replaced
that so that remains
um
and as far as how long adjudication can
take
a little surprise to see two years I
might have liked Lost but I wasn't going
to do anything about it well that's the
that's to allow time for the
um that's a very generous limit yeah
yeah but they're
in the recent past there have been
investigations that dragged on for much
longer than two years
we hope that that would not be the case
in the future right okay yeah I mean
having somebody under that cloud that
long seems to be a problem but I'm not
going to object to it at this point okay
any other comments questions
representative Schmidt
well the thing is it it permits a a
process of up to two years right it
doesn't say it requires two years they
could get potentially it could get done
with it quicker more quickly we will
hope that the expedited processes that
we're trying to create here will work
better than what we have in the
executive director is nodding in
agreement so it says they must hold the
final hearing within two years
and that's
we hope it'll be quicker all right any
other comments
all right thank you the motion is to
adopt Senate Bill 2107 with Amendment
and follow the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard
clerk Road chess representative groda
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Schultz yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith
yes and the chair yes 20 yay zero name
all right the motion passes 20-0 and the
objections to consent
all right seeing none we'll put this one
Senate Bill 106. representative grassy
you have a motion
uh yes Madam chairperson and I'd move
that we retain this bill oh second
okay do you wish to speak to your
emotions
um short not much though it's uh the
thing is this is something that the
child care providers have asked for
HHS says they can do this without going
to rules so they can do it themselves
possibly and what I'd like to see if
they can get that done this summer
that's fine if they don't then we may
have to force their hand
okay representative I think it was just
covered I'm good any other questions
clarification I didn't quite hear which
the all the requirements for these
certificates are in rules not in statute
just didn't hear the bill number very
cool Senate Bill 106. 106. thank you I'm
any
other comments questions
right the motion is to retain Senate
bill 106.
those in favor
oh the clerk called the little sorry
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo estaso
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
a bear yes representative Gerhard clerk
vocess representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Grassi yes representative
Davis yes representative Schmidt Schultz
yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes 20 years
all right
and I will say that I am writing on
behalf of the committee a letter to the
commissioner of hh-sc formally asking
them to initiate rulemaking on this
issue
I think
yeah we want them to do it so let's
okay
Senate Bill 105 representative lacques I
believe you have a second amendment
it's going to be to adopt an amendment
and if you give me a moment I'll have
your moment is it 1728 is it the one we
did in the subcommittee
I have two well it's House Bill 105.
excuse me that's my mistake extended
yes I'm uh but I can pass that to
representative Schmidt
okay so
um
the original intent of this bill
this bill concerns the information that
both um
a new mother is required to provide when
the child is born and also the
information that the facility
provides and
there was actually a committee that
Senator Rosenwald chaired that I was on
concerning this and the concern was
there's a lot of private information
that is required to be included
and there were in fact criminal
penalties if inaccurate information was
provided no it didn't didn't say
inaccurate it says false information
well false so there's knowingly false so
right
um
and so
I'm actually finally Amendment here
I have copies apologize are you looking
for the amendment yeah which I know I
have in here
okay so
um I'm all set I'll take it thank you
um thank you
so one was to get rid of the uh the
criminal penalties for the information
other than for the information that was
required to create a birth certificate
because uh if you you know that could be
used for purposes of fraud
um and the goal had been to keep that
information private at least if the
concern about the impact of not having
the information then the Senate amended
it but their Amendment basically made it
so it was impossible for the Secretary
of State to issue birth certificates
which is kind of a problem and there
just wasn't time to um
figure out
the process where we could keep as much
information private private as possible
and still not cause other problems
so the options would have been to retain
it to work on it but instead this
amendment 1728 h
uh keeps the part that decriminalizes it
uh you know the information that's
provided that is not related to the
birth certificate the other thing that
was the original bill is current statute
requires that the hospital or birthing
Place keeps the records basically for
eternity
and this drops it down to seven years
which is common for uh for other records
representative oh yeah I'll let do you
have a comment I do well I don't know if
there was a second but if there's a
second I'll make a second um
representative ruckus's motion to adopt
the amendment
anyone else I I
the seven years is because
if a parent neglects to get a birth
certificate immediately upon the birth
of a child the most usual time they come
come back for it is when the kid goes to
school
and therefore seven years of retention
of this record will allow
um
a birth certificate
a delayed birth certificate without as
much hassles it would be if they had to
try and recreate memories and things
like that
um
while retaining privacy I thought that
it was very important that we not burden
the parents I don't mind so much
burdening the hospitals but the parents
should not be burdened any more than
necessary
so
that's why seven years yes
representative a bear
thank you madam chair
in my time here in the legislature
there's been very few bills that have
gotten me really really fired up or that
I've thought about for several days
after we heard them so I'm proud to be
part of this although it's not perfect
and where we all wanted to go with it it
anyway I can't represent a Bailey
well a question there was an earlier
Amendment uh 1504 what happened to that
so which seems to include the same
material as this most current one in the
final piece this one is it had earlier
sections it's simpler I can help with
that it's this in the subcommittee that
a memo is not adopted it was done this
one was the one that was adopted so it
took out the part about the mother's
medical records correct yeah record
number correct
gold
just as a genealogist and also as
someone who handled data for dcyf I want
to thank the committee and everybody
who's worked so hard in this it raised a
lot of concern across a lot of sectors
that work with the data and you all did
a great job thank you
any other comments representative shuitt
thank you madam chair
um just to chime in
um I agree with representative Aber that
this bill presented quite a few issues
and at first I thought that retention
was the way to go however I'm
particularly glad to see that something
is coming forward so that we can get rid
of the penalty that was out there thank
you okay
anyone else
representative Schmidt thank you madam
chair so I I I want to just make sure
the record reflects the fact that we had
a lot of public input uh with regard to
uh the absolutely essential aspect of uh
the medical ASP uh
screening that's done that goes into the
records uh that uh that there's some
extremely pernicious uh childhood uh
abnormalities that that can occur which
can be a you know virtually limited if
they're screened immediately or
virtually immediately uh and if if this
if this information is not
obtained and acted upon uh you can have
people's lives dramatically uh
diminished as a result of it so I think
the public should know that that we are
going to still support that kind of
information gathering without uh putting
the public in general Jeopardy
especially the the the knowingly false
information aspect of the existing
statute that we don't want so thank you
all right thank you other other
representative leckis yeah just for the
record
um
you know even if this bill as originally
written had passed it would actually we
did get that testimony people were
concerned about it
um but even the original bill would not
have stopped the requirement that that
early childhood testing be done that's
you know there's there's other statute
and things that set that in place and
it's an obligation on the doctor in the
health care facility
so whether or not HHS had the
information on what was done I mean that
was still an obligation and so while I
understand you know people were
concerned that this that might impact it
I don't believe it really would have
anyway
okay
all right seeing none the motion is to
adopt Amendment 1728 to Senate bill 105.
clerking call the role
representative Simon yes representative
blakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Aber yes
Roseanne Gerhard
clerkflow.js representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Schultz yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes 28-09
all right the amendment is adopted
representative blackis you have a motion
um I move
um not to pass with Amendment on Senate
bill 105.
is there a second
by representative Gould
all right
any further discussion comments
questions
all right in that case the clerkin
called the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey
yes
representative yes representative true
yes representative Dolan yes
representative Aber yes representative
Gerhard
yes representative Schmidt
yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes 20 years
okay the motion passes 20-0 any
objection to consent
okay seeing um we'll put this one on
consent
[Music]
rep representative Simon you have on
Senate Bill 53 you love emotion yes
ma'am chair I would like to move
okay you should speak to your motion
um yes so um this bill dealt with
um new refrigerants that are being
released to the market because the uh do
the federal Clean Air Act uh the
refrigerants that we currently use are
going to be phased out over the next
period of time and so
um this amendment basically
um puts into building code
um the necessary code to make the new
refrigerants legal to produce and use in
the state of New Hampshire it's been
reviewed by the building code review
board and they're just looking for our
ratification
representative true do you wish to speak
so I view this as a a problem that has
been created uh by the Clean Air Act
and our reaction to it
so that
people are able to builders are able to
install the new refrigerant gases
because the the ones we currently are
using uh being uh
uh
withdrawn uh you stop throwing away
um
it's just something we have to do
um so I support the support team member
anyone else comments
definitely true thank you thank you
every word representative I do want to
clarify that when we um update
this Committee in the future will be
updating the building codes
and when we do update them this is going
to be part of the definition of the
building codes now so this will
automatically be part of the building
code updates should this need to change
okay great thank you yes the building
code review board
when that we go to a newer edition of
the building code we will they normally
include any amendments that are still
relevant that were adopted earlier
and I'd like to comment that this
merely in increases the number and type
of refrigerant that can be made in or
sold in or used in the state it doesn't
delete
the authority to use any existing
refrigerants or any equipment that uses
existing refrigerant it just says you
can also as an option use these others
and I think that that's
uh if they're going to be coming more
widely available we want to adopt that
position
all right seeing none the motion is to
adopt Amendment 1959 to excuse me 1951.
yeah
to Senate Bill 53 and the clerk can call
the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerard yes clerk coach
yes representative Grotto yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis
yes representative Schultz yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes 28-0 nay
okay
representative Simon
thank you madam chair I would like to
move
um out to pass on SB 53 with Amendment
second second by representative Schmidt
any further discussion
in that case the motion is to adopt
Senate Bill 53 with Amendment and the
clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey no
representative Santo nastasso
yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard
clerk Beau Jess representative yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Schultz yes
representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes
and the chair yes 19 yay one day
the motion passes 19 to 1. uh
representative Bailey do you plan on a
no okay thank you do you object to
consent
okay
in that case if no one else objects we
will put it on consent
and that's it
representative Simon leckis and grodus
you all you each owe me a committee
report at
soon as possible
I managed to volunteer for two of them
so I'll be busy on that one
representative grassy a retain a motion
to retain does not require a committee
reports here golden
all right anything anything else
and representative Schmidt has a comment
so ladies and gentlemen
and all the rest of you as well
um so we have a little event that is
happening uh and I need to provide
directions for those of you who don't
know how to get to Mattress Lobster and
Steakhouse on sheep Davis Road
I think 354
sheep Davis Road
um 354 is correct
Tom okay so we can so two
I I
Brad has directions available for those
um and those of you who do we will see
you there starting at 12 30. today
and Matt Santa nastasso
what can you are you working on it in
terms of coming down yay or nay
if you're coming I need to see your
is anybody missing a pen
yeah
I can do that
but
does it say anything
www.newfutures.org
reminder everyone who is the lead on a
retained bill
please schedule a meeting to figure out
what you're going to do on said retained
meal if you're going to wait till after
the Senate does anything that's okay as